welcome to an exclusive interview
by deutsche welle from washington dc
with wolfgang schmidt s head of the
federal chancellery and is currently in
washington dc to attend a meeting of the
munich security
conference minister schmit
welcome the relationship if
transatlantic relations
europe usa are more important than
ever at the moment  reason for the ukraine war but
how important is the usa for germany
is germany capable of defending
over russia even without the usa no but
that's why we're in a joint
nato alliance and of course the
usa is particularly important for
germany but also for europe and for
the  nato and that's why we work
so closely and well together because only like
him as an alliance can exist as an alliance of strong
partners in this world
but now we have seen in the united
nations that the world is not
really united very many countries
have the invasion  of russia in
ukraine  not condemned at all
or abstained and 50 percent
of the world population belongs to it how
united is the world really
first of
all 140 or 141
states condemned the aggressions of the russian
federation in the vote in the general assembly
that is important
at the same time it is so that many
States are worried about the effects this
war will have on them in
terms of
food security food prices in terms of
energy prices and that's why many
states in latin america in asia but
also in africa are asking a lot of questions and that's
why it's important to
keep making it clear that this is a  breaking
the law of nations that is an illegal action
to invade another country and
many states understand that and at the same
time we live in an
interdependent world and that many states of
course also have good relations with the
russian federation and that is why there
is a lot going on at the moment  dip
lomatik talked about
how to prevent such aggression from happening
again and
above all how to ensure that
this war in ukraine is ended as quickly as possible
a step that
germany also wants to
take is the chancellor at the g7 summit  he has already
said that he will take place in germany for the g7 summit in june
because germany holds the presidency and
would like to invite other countries,
especially the countries that
abstained, for example in the
vote in the united nations, which
includes south africa  how do you
want to convince these countries and have
they already promised will these
countries really take part yes that's
called the autoid and you can
be proud of that it's particularly important that the
four countries invited
india and indonesia and south africa and
senegal too at the moment  to send a signal
that if the g7 is the club of the
seven w  most important industrialized countries
that it's not just about
oneself or about europe, but that
the view is directed at the entire
world and that's why it's just as important
as the meetings with the
international organizations, which will
also come to schloss elmau at the end of june
where  this g7 summit
will take place i think that we have seen in
many talks with our
partners in india, for example, that they
are also very concerned about what
russia has done and that at the
same time, of course, they have questions
that also relate to their own situation
as far as the question of the
supply of food
or fertilizers is concerned, and we have to
talk about that, and that is why germany
, as the g7 presidency, has not
only now taken care of
ukraine being supported financially,
but also that many millions
are made available to
ensure the
food supply  India
has already
promised South Africa for humanitarian aid and how do
you want to convince these countries specifically
that they should stand
on the side of the West in this war? They have
promised, but it's not
about convincing them of something,
it's about that  discussing the situation in the world on an
equal footing
with each other
and olaf scholz
, in a speech in
the german federal parliament shortly after the invasion, used the concept of the
turning point relatives said that
the world is different after this attack
than before the attack and the
experience  we know that a country no
longer feels bound by
international law,
i.e. what the community of states then built up after the end
of the second world war in
1945 with the united nations
with regional organizations for
security and cooperation, that it
is a president from a
country  simply been ignored and
disregarded wor  and that has
consequences
and how the community of states works with
it, of course, that has to be discussed with one another.
an
individual state or an alliance of
states like the g7 cannot simply tell the other
and that's what it's about talking about it and also discussing
the consequences
with one another  move and you have to
see we are in a world that has
been through a serious crisis for more than two years
now with co
will which has led to many
developing countries but also
emerging countries being exposed to incredibly great pressure of a financial nature the health systems on the edge of the
the public
debt has risen sharply and
the international community
has mobilized a
great many funds a great deal at the world bank at the
international monetary fund but also
at the whu has thought about how we
can tackle this in solidarity and in that respect
there is a lot to talk about and it’s for it
there  nn such a g7 summit with this
outfit with the invitation of guests from
non-g 7 states extremely important
the group of 20 g20 that is also
an important group
and russia is still part of it
president biden has spoken out in favor of
excluding russia  will countries like india
and china possibly be able to
prevent that how to deal with
it could it actually be that at the
next
g-20 meeting in indonesia you will
see germany and russia sitting at the same table of
course everyone is now considering how
to deal with the fact that there is one country
no longer adheres to the
rules of international law, which were previously the basis for the
cooperation of the international
community i think it is good
that indonesia, as g20 presidency,
also invited president
selensky to the summit in bali and everything
else is now being
discussed very intensively how to  deal with the fact that
russia has behaved as
it is behaving  en we talk
a lot about a new world order that will emerge after this
turning point we talk a
lot about asia about africa the west
what is happening to latin america why
is brazil not
invited to the g7, for example, or mexico will
maybe
government consultations take place again with
brazil or is that out of the question
no, these are things that are happening now
the new government in germany has been
in office for a little over five months
so still or six months is relatively
new and of course you can’t do everything
at once but there are a lot of talks, a lot of
trips are also planned and of
course there are  at the moment all states
are talking to each other about this new
situation,
but you can't do everything at
once and latin america is also
very important for germany, many german companies
are active in mexico, in
brazil, in argentina, but in many other states and the diplomatic
relations between  germany and
latin america delicious are very old and
very good because we often
share the same values ​​and that
is why latin america is a very important
partner
president biden also describes this war
in ukraine as a war of
democracies against autocracies
would you think so too?  this is also
an intra-american discussion
i think it is very important to describe it in such a way
that we are dealing with an
alliance of multilateral
start who
find the rules-based world order correct who say
that multilateralism,
cooperation between states
based on legal rules, is
correct  and there is a country that
resists this order and there is
russia and if you look at
which states are really on the side of russia
then they are states like north korea
like syria like venezuela
and the main question here is
that they  rule-based order not
correct find  en and i think that is
the
debate that is the main focus at the moment it is of course also a question of the countries becoming
independent, especially
as far as energy is concerned, germany can really do without the
energy from russia, do without the
energy imports from russia
above all is  It is important that we have to do without fossil fuels as quickly as possible because
of climate protection and to stop climate change
and the climate crisis
and that is
why the new federal government in Germany has set itself
the very ambitious goal
of being
CO2-free by 2045 and that means that
we
do what we have been doing for 250 years,
namely burning oil and coal and gas,
running our industry,
but also moving around
and keeping our homes warm or
cold, that we have to change that in less than 25
years, that is an
unbelievable transformational task
and this aspect of climate protection and
that we  have to do to
stop climate change is now being
supplemented by the consideration that it is
also about freedom and
independence and that is why
we are now accelerating exactly this
energy
transition, i.e. the phase-out of fossil fuels, starting with the dependence on coal,
we had already decided  before
the war was started
by russia that we want to
phase out the burning of coal by 2030 if possible
and now we see to it that
the coal that is still being burned
no longer comes from russia and that
will now take place everywhere in europe
the dependencies  the
interdependencies are
greater or smaller depending on the energy source
, but it is important to me that you always keep an
eye on the rest of the world, because
if we now simply switch off the Russian gas, which flows
primarily via pipelines from the east
to the west to europe,
then that will have it  incredible
effects on the r  est in the world
i mentioned before that
fertilizer production is based on
gas and if this russian gas is
suddenly no longer available on the world market
, it will have very far-reaching consequences for many
countries outside of europe
and i
think it is important that these are
also dealt with with the  keep an eye on it and what do you
answer when it is said
that germany is also
financing the war by continuing to
import gas from russia
that is not entirely correct so first of all
the russian federation has
very large foreign currency reserves at the
central bank we have
a large one through sanctions  partly frozen
so the funds that are located abroad
you have no access to them
but nevertheless president putin has
ensured since 2014 that his economy
becomes more and more independent the second is
that
the weapons that are built due to
the embargo of
high technology are no longer on
western ones  technolog  ie that you
would have to pay in dollars or in euros are bought
, but that he
pays in rubles and he can print rubles indefinitely
, that increases inflation
and we can see that, but he is not
dependent on the income from oil or
gas and it may show  a bit
that we have a situation that every
day russian gas runs through a pipeline
through ukraine so while
russia is waging war against ukraine
and ukraine is defending itself militarily against
this inversion,
at the same time every day russian gas flows
through ukrainian pipelines and the
russian gas company  every
day pays a transfer fee to ukraine
for the transit you can see
this mutual dependence on
gas is a reality that also
applies in ukraine what is now in europe the
european union is trying to become
independent as quickly as possible
and to open up other sources
such as liquefied gas lng from usa from
zb  but not only in the usa, so there are
also many
business opportunities for other countries and it
is only important that liquid gas will also be
a transitional technology for
the next few years, maybe decades,
but then a lot will also be put on green
hydrogen and there are of
course  many other countries from
latin america but also from africa are there
and have great chances
to generate new revenue and when could
germany get by without russian gas
that's hard to say but
it's not so much about germany
alone but other european countries
union are much
more dependent on russian gas we
have already significantly reduced our dependency, which used to be 55
percent,
but it also affects other
european countries and it affects
the world if russian gas is
no longer available to the world market because it
just no longer through the pipelines that
exist after  if it can come to europe
then it simply cannot be
diverted there are not so many pipelines
that then go to china or pipelines
that then liquefy the gas
so that it is then
available to the world market as lng,
but the gas is no longer available
that  would have the effect that the
prices for gas would rise overall
maybe germany can still afford the
whole thing in europe
but many others just can't and in
this respect we should also keep an eye on the
effects worldwide effects there
is really a
danger that it could lead to a bigger war
could come that is always a great
danger and you should never act out of fear
nato does that
too germany doesn't do that either but it's
about acting responsibly
and everyone
in the alliance agrees that
the war could even spread to other
countries  a confrontation a
military confrontation with a
nuclear power n  ot responsible and
accountable would be a real red line
a textbook when such a
nato entry into the war
is available it doesn't exist and that
makes it so complicated to talk about it in such an
abstract way, but it
is the concrete decisions
and always to be taken into account that
summarizes the Russian one  side also makes it
clear to the russian side that
things are not acceptable and
germany is profiling itself as a
leading power not only in europe
but also worldwide but
germany can actually also be a
leader on the
international level germany
acts primarily through the european
union and  that's also what
[music]
president after rome, what the federal chancellor
tried to convey to the
russian president in the talks before the invasion, the times when individual powers divided the world
among themselves and
thought about going into one river are over  we do
n't believe d  as it will be a uni or bipolar
world but there will be many
power centers in latin
america in africa and the european union with
currently 470 million
inhabitants will also be such a power center
germany alone with its 83
million inhabitants
is far too small for that  acting through
the european union and
closing again for this, the friendship and
the relationship with the usa is of course
particularly important
, but we are always
dealing with democracy in 2024, of
course, there will be elections here again and there
is a definite possibility that
if  not ex-president donald trump
maybe a new president will come
as well a conservative possibly
with national interests as the first
priority on the agenda what would
happen then would germany lose important
partners and can only
dance with the hall and that applies to
friends as well as to less  friendly
regime with which one  it has to do,
but i think it's
important to trust that the democracies are
strong, that the institutions
work, and that no matter who holds the office
of president,
there is a stable
democracy with checks and balances
that ensures that  the
alliance commitments are taken
seriously that international
cooperation is valued and
that's something i'm experiencing
now in this time of crisis that
here in washington that's in the usa there's
a great deal of cooperation between the
two
parties that are dominant that they're
very much in agreement  are in foreign policy and
that the internal party or
the party disputes between the parties
in domestic policy and many other
issues relating to ukraine and alliance issues are taking a back seat
at the moment
and i think that is a good
sign